[Music]
it's seven o'clock you're watching a sky
news special programme war in ukraine
putin's next move
coming up we'll get the latest on the
ground and ask whether president putin
can claim any kind of success so far
we'll be looking at the changing russian
strategy after the focus shifted to the
donbass following the failure to take
kiev
as the un's secretary general visits
moscow we'll discuss the west's role in
the war and what the conflict means for
the future of nato
and we'll be asking what a peace
settlement could look like and how this
war might end
[Music]
welcome to a sky news special program
war in ukraine putin's next move
in the next hour we'll be joined by
experts from the west and russia to
analyze the war so far where it could go
next and crucially how it might end
well let's introduce then our panel for
this evening joining us from moscow
sergey markov director of the institute
of political studies who's a former
member of the russian parliament and a
former spokesman for president putin
also in moscow journalist and political
analyst dimitri babich from berlin we're
joined by wolfgang richter a retired
colonel in the german army and military
expert at the german institute for
international and security affairs and
here in westminster louise jones former
officer in the british army intelligence
corps and head of intelligence at
mckenzie intelligence services so that's
our panel but let's begin by reminding
ourselves how the russian campaign has
evolved since it began more than two
months ago now and take a look at the
current situation on the ground in
ukraine our defence and security analyst
professor michael clark is at the screen
this war began on the 24th of february
with the russian invasion
and the original idea was that it would
all be over by the 8th of march so this
was phase 1 of a three-phase war
the fir the first phase was where the
russians were going to capture kiev
within the first 48 or 72 hours grab the
government and deal with any unrest
elsewhere by the 8th of march it was a
complete and utter failure so then they
moved to phase 2 and phase 2 was
transforming this sort of arrangement to
more of a
a maneuverous warfare and so what they
tried to do in the maneuver phase was to
surround the cities to actually put
chernihev and sumi and kharkiv and mario
paul of course under pressure but they
found that they really couldn't do that
very easily because they didn't really
have enough troops to do it they didn't
really have the right equipment to do it
so they were left outside the cities
just bombarding civilian areas that
wasn't getting them very far they did
take cursion which was the only city
that this second phase of the war
actually gave them
that wasn't going very well so the third
phase of the war began about two weeks
ago and the russians said
really we didn't intend to do any of
that all of that was just preparation
for the fact that we really wanted to
consolidate territory in the donbass and
in the land bridge towards the crimea
and so this third phase of the war is
the phase that we're in now where
they've redeployed the forces that were
beaten quite badly beaten around kiev
around the outside of the clock to
re-engage in this big offensive in the
donbass so that's where we are today
phase three of the war which will be the
most critical phase for the next few
months and what this is based on is is
drawing a famous line that i keep
talking about between kharkiv and mario
paul to close this salient this big
salient which will include about 40
percent of ukrainian forces on the wrong
side of the salient to surround them
that's quite a big thing to do and so
immediately what the russians are trying
to do is to draw a smaller line from
israel they're fighting very hard south
of isiam down to donetsk and catch most
of the ukrainian forces that they're
interested in in that part of the uh of
the territory meanwhile incursion quite
a lot is going on there the russians are
pushing again incursion because there
are rumors rumors that maybe they will
try to have a referendum incursion on
the first of may uh in order to show
that the citizens of kershaw really want
to join the russian federation so that's
the situations is at the moment still
very fluid still everything to play for
professor michael clark there with his
analysis so clearly the invasion has not
gone according to plan for the kremlin
particularly in the first phase of the
campaign as michael clark was describing
there so can president putin claim any
degree of success in the war so far
let's talk to our panel in and starting
with you louise jones i mean clearly at
the moment it's a story of failures and
quite spectacular failures in the north
and more limited gains in the south and
the east yeah so it's very clear from
the beginning that russia's grand aim
was to try and take kiev was to remove
the government of president zielinski
install a regime that is much more
favorable to them as we've seen they
never even really got close to being
able to achieve that aim and they really
had to pull out of that northern region
completely um they have restated their
aims and saying oh well okay perhaps all
we ever wanted was to uh consolidate
controlling the donbass perhaps we'll
look at trying to take odessa and
frankly these are quite ambitious aims
when you look at the capability and
compass capacity of the russian forces
now so really i think we're just going
to see these aims change over the next
few months and just become very very
much more limited in what they're trying
to achieve okay let's bring in some
voices from moscow sergey markov um
would you go along with that i mean
clearly the campaign as planned for all
those months did not work initially
yeah that's right
that's about declare first plan
was that russian troops will move to the
biggest city
yes
uh and others and as a result
uh the ukrainian government uh could do
ethosal city uh and it could be a vacuum
of power and this [ __ ] homopower will be
taken by uh anti-fascist pro-russian uh
political forces and as a result this is
kind of new government of ukraine will
uh claim uh that negotiation with russia
and starting the process okay
okay i mean that's your that that's you
that's your analysis but you know we're
asking why uh russia with all its huge
military might failed to take kiev it's
the military situation i want to
concentrate on dmitry
um was there this some kind of thinking
in the kremlin that
ukraine would rapidly capitulate and
indeed welcome russian forces
uh
well maybe a part of the russian
leadership had these illusions but i
don't think president putin himself had
them
and uh i'm not sure that the plan was
exactly of what professor michael black
described at least i never heard any
russian generals i never saw any
documents
uh which would indicate that the plan
was to take here in three days or four
days not everyone understood that it was
going to be a much longer more difficult
operation
because let me remind you the war did
not start on the february 24th the war
had been going on for eight years
and the russians know very well that
ukrainian army has some very
capable units that have been fighting in
donbass and look uh
you know the the version that putin has
been pushing that
the russian invasion
kind of prevented ukrainian attackers
against donbass
this version is given sign meet by the
fact that the russian army so far uh has
not been able to secure doughnuts
i want to get your analysis general
richter on the failure of russian forces
in the north particularly around kiev
and indeed other cities this this idea
of encirclement and a rapid failure by
ukraine it just didn't transpire why did
russia think that might happen
i think the
failure started with the wrong
assessment on the top leadership
if you have the assessment that things
would turn out to be very similar to the
operations in 2014
then you of course fail
uh to achieve anything because you think
again the ukrainian forces would not uh
be in a position to find to fight
strongly
uh parts of the ukrainian army uh
particularly the ukrainian black sea
fleet
in 2014
changed sides and
some others didn't want to fight so the
the brunt of the
fighting rested on the volunteer
battalions and this situation is totally
different
ukraine has now developed a kind of
homogeneity that is historical
there is a clear national identity of
ukraine and that is what president putin
underestimated he even denied this
identity
and if you start with that assessment
from top down you make all the mistakes
that were made that means you are not
prepared for real intensive fighting you
have six parallel
axis of advance
emphasis and then
you have
failures of logistical
lines of communication
and even the tactical on the technical
level
the
skills to fight an arm combined arms
battle were not so developed ah okay
i just want to i just want to continue
on what you described there wolfgang
richter about some
the failures of analysis by the kremlin
before they started the war
this phase of the war louise jones i
mean does that fundamentally come down
to intelligence failures we do hear
that there is from what we can tell
disquiet within the kremlin about the
military intelligence that they were
getting before they launched the attack
particularly on kiev yeah i think that's
very clear so um you know it's easy to
characterize sometimes the kremlin as
you know information is not being passed
between those who need to know and
analyze properly um and i think the
facts have borne themselves out you know
so really in the kermit are people
telling the truth even when it's not
what the president wants to hear
clearly they're not you know we've just
recently heard that oh well their plan
was not to take care of in three days we
never expected to take kiev so far so um
that kind of implies well what was the
plan then was it to send thousands of
troops to nearby kiev be there for a
couple of weeks lose thousands of troops
and then withdraw and on the way back
dig up a load of radioactive earth
around chernobyl was that the plan
appears to be what we're hearing that
was what the intelligence led them to do
a few questions here well let's uh put
them to sergey marco first of all sergey
markov does president putin get told
what he wants to hear or does he get
told the plain truth about the failures
it's absolutely clear that uh pure's
stage what have been not so much
successful
because it's clear that russian troops
had to withdraw uh kiev turning up and
sumai uh regions
and uh now uh as a result russia had to
change its uh
military and political strategy
uh it's uh
though i mean much more consolidated
than our russian uh political and
terrorist services i think expected and
russia and our military effort will
concentrate exactly in donbasso reactive
support to surrounded then to crash uh
ukrainian army in the first stage it was
no
uh rocket missiles uh strikes all the
headquarters of ukrainian army and was
on contrary appeal of vladimir putin to
the uh generals of the ukrainian army uh
to take power in their hands and then to
come to some kind of agreement with
russia but it was absolutely not
successful now we have uh efficiently
change our strategy and uh not uh to
have a brotherhood with ukrainian army
but to have a real war with the
ukrainian army and to crush it okay and
uh
how to pass
effective uh of course we don't know uh
the ground uh though on the ground will
show us all right we're gonna get it
we're gonna get on to the next phase of
the of the russian strategy in a moment
or two but dimitri babich that loss
of troops 15 20 000 we hear dead tanks
aircraft other military equipment i mean
it's looking like a colossal failure
which will affect the next phase of the
campaign
i don't believe your figure is correct
15 000 is too much
uh you know i have personal connections
with several commanders on the ground
what do you hear and uh they will report
they all report that the bosses were
like
from five to seven percent
of uh the soldiers in their units hold
on hold on i'm just doing the math we're
hearing 190 000. so seven percent of 190
000 is just under what 14 000 13 000 or
so
uh well first uh the combat unions they
are not all these 150 000 were
concentrated on the border also take
into account the fact that there are
logistical uh support troops no i think
that the real figure is of course not 15
000. although yes it is counted in
thousands
uh talking about what louise jones said
uh i think that we can consulted with
very few people before starting this
operation because it is my uh not only
impression but i'm almost sure that for
example uh foreign minister lavrov was
not informed about this operation
because on the eve of the operation when
the security council met he was asked uh
to provide his advice uh lavrov said
okay all of our prepositions to the
western countries were turned down
uh we have been uh kind of rejected by
nato but i think this work should
continue it makes sense to continue
working on the diplomatic rules if
lavrov had known that uh in two days uh
the invasion would begin he of course
would not have out of this world so at
least until
12 or i don't know 20 hours before the
operation he was not informed about it
which means that putin kept his
information to a very close circle of
his advisors as for him not been told
truth i can tell you why more than
russia was the way you described it the
problem is that we have hundreds of
thousands almost millions immigrants
from ukraine who are very angry with the
ukrainian government with mr poroshenko
and writer luis vasiliansky and
they have access to television so they
they kept saying that this regime is
cruel that it is corrupt that it is weak
you know right before the invasion uh
zelianski shut down two of the country's
main television channels so dozens of
journalists arrived in moscow and uh of
course in the public the mood was that
this regime is not only bad okay so
the future strategy in a moment or two
but we must take a break so if you all
stay with us we'll talk to wolfgang
richter next but uh you're watching sky
news tonight and coming up as i say
we'll be discussing the russian strategy
in ukraine how it's changed after that
failure to capture the capital kiev
[Music]
[Music]
the six year anniversary is a critical
milestone for us it's a moment of
reflection uh looking at who we have
been how we have been and where we are
going so
for us it's it's a matter of
glorying in our culture the things that
have made us who we are and they this
confluence of cultures and ethnicity
that has woven itself into the jamaican
mosaic uh and all four fathers saw it
well by having a motto out of many one
people that's who jamaica really is out
of many one people and we want to glory
in that diversity and to show the world
that our rich culture and our diverse
offerings uh represent a little piece of
them we are a small island state
but the largest in the english-speaking
caribbean characterized by very strong
biodiversity lush green vegetation warm
climate we have a
temperate
climate running through the entire year
we have a wonderful waterfalls and
stalagmites and stalactites
and food jamaica is known for its
cuisine
excellent for delicious and electable
jamaican cuisine
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back so when russia launched its
invasion of ukraine a couple of months
ago ground forces crossed the border in
the north the east and the south the
plan was to surround and seize key
ukrainian cities including kiev and
bring about a swift surrender of course
it didn't work and russia's forces have
withdrawn from the north to concentrate
now on the eastern donbass region so to
what extent is this new strategy from
president putin which was brought about
by a military failure let's explore the
strategy now then and wolfgang richter
first of all um
what is the strategy as you see it and
can it work it's clearly concentrating
on the east the donbass and the south
um yeah let me start with uh just a
short comment to what dmitry babich has
said when it comes to the uh
failure of the phase
one
um he talked about the
losses if you speak about ten thousand
or even eight thousand of uh people that
died the soldiers that died in the war
then of course you have to add three
times as much uh wounded that means the
loss is tremendous it's one-fifth to one
fourth of the original force that
started the operation and the second of
course there might be uh hundreds of
thousands of immigrants who are
not happy with the ukrainian governments
but there are 40 millions of ukrainians
who fight with an admirable spirit of
resistance for their country for its uh
for the country for this sovereignty and
territorial integrity and that should
not be
uh
that that you should have in mind when
you talk about second the second phase
now let me just look at the strategy
uh obviously moscow learned some lessons
from the phase one
it has now
created a clear main emphasis of the
battle
it has shortened the line of engagement
it has chosen
a terrain that is more suited for the
tactical battle groups
which disposed a lot of armor and
artillery uh heavy fire and are not so
much suited for the fighting in cities
and that was maybe also their failure of
the first phase they get they were uh
they were good they got
broke down by city fighting and had a
lot of losses there so maybe
the chances are a little bit better the
failures
might not be repeated on the other hand
we see the ukrainian side
with a very
surprising technical skill that we are
always in a position to also swap
armored attacks by small counter-attacks
by anti-armor operations
etc so i guess some terrain might be
taken
but it is not clear yet not at all what
the outcome of this phase will be okay
um sergey markov um what do you see now
as the altered russian strategy to
encircle the parts of the ukrainian army
that are based in the donbass and extend
the
south all the way perhaps even to
transnistria take odessa
um of course uh where it's appeared to
be that ukrainian army more strong than
we expected but this ukrainian missouri
strange honey would say partly i'm your
21st century it's uh interesting
combination uh
a russian soldier because 90 percent of
them speak russian language
uh including fascist officer because the
level of massification of with officer
corp during these seven years appeared
to be much more bigger than it was are
they fighting for democracy mr markov
no no no no no no democracy forget about
this what about
ukraine it's fully puppet regime of
united south america and i didn't finish
a russian soldier fascist officer and
led by american general
because most of the even formerly
ukrainian generals they had been
moderated by uh uh uh advisors from
united states from uh united states army
so it's strong commission also
okay listen i'm not gonna listen to any
more of this so so the americans are
training fascists
who um some of them are russians who are
to fight right i mean honestly
well we're discussing the strategy
yeah okay uh louise jones in terms of
the the russian strategy the ambitions
now as we discussed in the first quarter
of the programme they um
failed in the north uh that's some badly
battered forces that they have to lick
their wounds and presumably some of them
are going to be redeployed in the east
can they do what they want to do so it's
very difficult to reconstitute badly
damaged units and then redeploy them in
a short amount of time so they're really
going to struggle to bring really much
of that manpower to bear the forces that
they have in the south east they'll also
struggle to really mount any kind of
major offensive because they will have
to be very focused on holding the ground
that they want um the ukraine is
obviously so welcoming of the russians
that the russians won't be able to just
leave the city they'll have to leave a
large proportion of their forces behind
and you know the idea that you know
there's
president zelinski with some sort of
puppet is just ridiculous you know he
was elected you know on a very clear
pro-peace uh platform and just to
address that point i mean i mean to be
fair to sergey mark i mean clearly and
we're going to get on to it more in
another part of the program
nato forces americans amongst them
british canadians others have been
training the ukrainians no doubt about
that yeah and nato uh the us the uk you
know they're they're training forces all
around the world you know they're
they're from you know training
anti-poaching operations in in africa
you know are we saying they when they
train anti-poachers that's some sort of
pro-nazi training regime of course not
and i think you know
flattering russia a little bit here
america's been very clear about the
focuses of its uh foreign policy is very
much focused on the asia pacific the
idea that they're you know spinning some
sort of game in ukraine purely aimed at
russia i think russia is flattering
itself there okay just dmitry babich i
just want to stick
with the military side
of this
discussion
and what does russia what does president
putin want to achieve now because this
will set us up for another part of the
discussion about what might end this
conflict so so how much territory do you
think he wants
well i mean
you cannot talk here about military
affairs without talking about politics
and ideology because it is a very
ideological war it is a very political
war and i will only give you facts so on
the military side
i think the plan is to defeat
the professional part of the ukrainian
army the part that can use
the sophisticated weapons provided by
nato you know that it was announced
today in ramstein that nato already
provided since the beginning of the
russian invasion as you call it nato
provided 5 billion dollars worth of
military equipment to ukraine and
probably more because the german
chancellor admitted that there were a
lot of secret shipments that were not
mentioned anywhere making it sound as if
that's the wrong thing to do ukraine is
a sovereign nation which has been
invaded by its much much bigger neighbor
there are many conflicts in the world uh
and usually the ethics is not to provide
weapons so that not to extinguish the
fire with gasoline what the west is
doing right now is exactly extinguishing
the fire with gasoline
i'm sorry it's absolutely clear that uh
president biden and the european leaders
want this court to continue
because they encourage mr zielenski to
change his position at the negotiating
table
first in the first day he talked about
utility he talked about agreeing not to
make ukraine a part of nato then he
dropped all these promises
obviously after talks with western
leaders and talking about
you said what does russia want
basically the reason why russia was
successful in the east and in the south
is very simple these are russian
speaking regions
and russian language was uh
discriminated against well russia seems
to be killing an awful lot of russian
speaking citizens who uh you say want to
be part of russia what about
what about the thousands of people being
bombarded and massacred in mariupol
i admire your way of moderating this
discussion when you hear something that
goes against your line you just repeat
what you said before against my life
what's the facts mr babbage it's the
fact yeah i will i will tell you the
facts
i will tell you the facts unfortunately
when you fight a very aggressive
nationalistic regime such as the regime
of saddam hussein for example you kill a
lot of people whom you are trying to
liberate uh this is what the americans
and the british did in many places in
the world well at least being honest no
no now the russians are doing it okay
we're going to take another break you'll
get plenty more time to make your points
later on in this program it's sky news
tonight and coming up as the un
secretary-general visits president putin
in moscow we'll be discussing the west's
role in this war
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
now then the secretary general of the
united nations has called for a
ceasefire in ukraine as soon as possible
during a visit to moscow for talks with
president putin antonio guterres said
humanitarian corridors must be set up to
get people out of marijuana calling the
port city a crisis within a crisis
bird president putin told mr gutierrez
that it's ukraine that's blocking the
evacuation of civilians from mariupol
our moscow correspondent diana magnay
reports
vladimir putin taking his seat at the
long table with the un secretary general
at the other end it evolved fast into a
debate on international law but antonio
gutierrez made it clear how he views
russia's special military operation
we strongly believe
that the violation of the territorial
integrity of any country
fully contradicts the un charter
and we are deeply concerned
in connection with what's happening uh
now
and we believe that
there was an invasion into the territory
of ukraine
mr gutierrez had already met with
russia's foreign minister and goes on
next to kiev this thursday his mission
he says to ensure humanitarian corridors
out of mariupol
vladimir putin insisted that that was
happening already
[Music]
foreign
the un secretary general was criticized
for this trip especially for coming to
moscow first vladimir zelinsky asking
what he would see here there are no
corpses scattered along kutuzovsky he
said which is the road that i'm on now
the measure of how successful this trip
has been will be whether mr gutierrez
has managed to organize a ceasefire in
some kind of humanitarian corridor which
the people of mariupol and especially
those in the azov style steel works feel
that they can trust
at the ramstein air base in germany nato
defense ministers met to discuss further
military aid to ukraine on top of the
five billion dollars already pledged
with germany adding 50 gephardt
anti-aircraft tanks to the mix
ukraine clearly believes that it can win
and so does everyone here
have much more to do
ukraine needs our help to win today
and they will still need our help when
the war is over
and here a reminder of why this must end
drone footage provided by the
self-proclaimed luhansk people's
republic showing what's left of a
village once on the ukrainian side of
the line of contact now under russian
control
absolute devastation not a single
building intact
just a special military operation russia
calls this
but it comes at a terrible cost
dynamic sky news moscow
so let's then discuss the west's role in
this conflict and what the war could
mean for the future of the nato military
alliance colonel richter first of all i
mean there's no doubt that nato is
deeply involved in this conflict and
going to get further involved even if
it's only by the supply of military
equipment and uh given your background
can i ask you a specific question first
of all is germany in your view doing
enough even with the announcement today
of the supply of those tanks
i think germany is doing what other nato
nations are also doing
there is no difference
because
germany sent anti-aircraft and on
anti-tank weapons
and other goods and now we are
discussing heavier weapons
the real point here is that germany
wants to go together with other allies
and not have a special role in that
and when it comes to the latest
development and indeed one can
assess that ukrainians need air cover
and they need anti-aircraft weapons and
they need anti-armor that's the reason
why now
we discuss also the delivery of
so-called
anti-aircraft
tank
gephardt systems
which
will have to
undergo some some time of course before
they are
combat ready and we have to think about
training etc etc cetera could you see
that training sorry sorry to interrupt
uh ken richter but could you see that
training ultimately taking place on
ukrainian soil nato forces
nato forces crossing that border
no not at all there's a clear uh
firewall
nato all nato states have clearly said
we will not get involved in military
operations in ukraine but we should not
forget that ukraine is the sovereign
country that was attacked by another
country with a superior army and ukraine
has all the right to defend
itself and its sovereignty and
territorial integrity and
that is of course in line with
international law with article 51 of the
charter of the united nations and all
other states it's of course the right to
support a nation that
fights for independence but if i may i
want to make a remark on something which
i cannot let go this way first there is
a miss which was
portrayed here by my russian colleagues
of this fascist government in kiev
president zelesky was democratically
elected that we have a multi-party
system the right-wing nationalist
parties have got less than 2.5 percent
in the last election so we should
not distort the facts here
and 40 million of population that show
an
admirable resistance spirit tell another
story and that includes of course
russian
speakers
and 470 advisers that were indeed there
in in the
area of libya
did not
create the spirit of the whole
population that is supporting the army
but they could only
maybe train weapons or some other skills
so
russia underestimated the national
identity and homogeneity of the ukraine
nation and this is a basic mistake which
is still there and it was also the
reason maybe for the failure and to the
western role
western the western role was not to
create the war as or to want the war no
the opposite was true
the western statesman warned before of
the war for example federal chancellor
schultz shortly before the war started
want
warned uh of uh the uh of starting the
war and said also clearly
that nato accession of ukraine is not on
the agenda
remember that that is that is a reality
remember the chancellor's chancellor
yeah and the chancellor's visit to
moscow um dimitri babich just on this
issue of nato um foreign minister lavrov
said that uh russia
is now fighting a proxy war against nato
because of this huge supply of armaments
and now regards those supply lines as
legitimate targets
well if uh holden richter was about to
speak for more than one minute i will
also speak a little more than one minute
uh yes well since these weapons are
coming to the front line since they will
be used against russian soldiers like in
any war of course the
russia may hit some targets on the
territory of ukraine not outside
destroying these weapons
some of them may be dangerous for europe
too i mean cnn reported that u.s has no
idea where all the stinger missiles that
they support ukraine went let me remind
you what happened to steal the missiles
that the united states sent to
afghanistan they became very dangerous
weapons in the hands of the terrorists
so uh it is a huge issue who is flooding
ukraine with weapons and for what
purpose i think it will be
a danger for everyone in european
countries
uh as for democracy in ukraine uh in
2010
president yanukovych was illegal
and he was
and he was voted in power by people from
the east and from the south of ukraine
from those regions which are now yes
welcoming russian troops
uh as for persecution of opposition in
ukraine the leader of the biggest
opposition party was first put under
house arrest by mr
and now mr zelianski wants to exchange
him as a prisoner of war with russians
this is the way he treats his opposition
russia and russia has kidnapped elected
officials from parts of ukraine that it
has taken on the issue of nato sergey
martin tell me the name
of the issue on the issue of nato
one of the original aims the continuing
aim of russia is of course to keep nato
at bay to stop its eastward expansion
it seems that it's failed in that that
it's backfired that uh russia wanted
less nato now it's getting more of it
we're seeing the finns the swedes of
course the ukrainians and others wanting
to join nato
uh
of course it's negative for russia if
sweden and finland will uh
give up their neutrality and will
join nato it's uh will uh increase uh
nato's threat uh to the russia
and of course we see consolidation of
nato right now and one of the
possibility which i uh we regard as
possible uh the concept of global nato
will be implemented as a result probably
japan
south korea and australia also will
join nato of course this also will lead
to the increasing
a threat to the not only to the russia
but uh to the china but uh it's uh no
which was we expected uh uh we're
talking about increasing of
aggressiveness of uh nato uh it's
exactly what we could see in
ukraine but uh same time uh
you need to try to ignore
uh to ignore uh concerned about security
of such countries like russia and china
and uh you may know that uh one of the
main goal of russian operation is
denisification of ukraine right and yeah
whatever that may be
okay right
if you interact with
we've heard it we've given you your time
to say that and uh we're not going to
discuss that anymore because we are
discussing nato and louise jones uh last
thought give me your take on how nato's
handling this
i mean in terms of its cohesion because
clearly there are stresses and strains
of course there are yeah well first of
all i think it's a bit um disingenuous
to talk about the expansion of nato nato
didn't expand
applying for membership became more
popular i wonder why that would be why
would people want to join such a
defensive organization
and i don't think we've ever seen nato
so unified you know even when you look
back to the beginnings of the iraq and
afghanistan conflict they weren't nearly
as unified as this uh and not only you
know with the election of macron
obviously a vote there by the french
public for the um more pro-ukrainian
candidate um and then you've seen
germany now taking steps that would you
never have imagined them taking and
they've only taken these as a result of
direct result of russian's actions in
ukraine so great master strategy again
there and finland and sweden for a very
long time have never even countenanced
joining nato
so for them it looks like it's very
likely that it will go ahead now and
again you know this isn't nato expanding
nato hasn't uh threatened finland or
sweden in any way they've just clearly
identified that is there is now a threat
from their large neighbor and nato is
the way to guarantee that if you're a
democratic nation that wants the
democratic will of your elections to be
respected the best way to do that is to
have nato guaranteeing it okay uh time
to move on you're watching a sky news
tonight special program on ukraine now
coming up we're going to be asking what
a peace settlement between russia and
ukraine could look like and how this war
and perhaps when will it end
[Music]
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland
the very issue that's been the source of
tension here for generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea it took the british monarchy a
century
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
welcome back in the final part of
tonight's program we're going to discuss
the potential for a peace settlement
between russia and ukraine and how this
war could end speaking to sky news today
the uk armed forces minister said that
president putin is making unsound
military decisions such as his desire to
declare some kind of victory by the 9th
of may that's the day that russia marks
the end of the second world war victory
day so how close is russia to seizing
the donbass in eastern ukraine would
that be a satisfactory outcome for
vladimir putin and would ukraine of
course accept that outcome and perhaps
the loss permanent loss of crimea if it
bought about peace well let's discuss
that first of all sergey markov um
is the ninth of may some kind of
deadline for president putin
uh it's you know this was not war for
the uh territories russia has a lot of
charities
you may know and russia has a lot of
population
and russia doesn't get more uh
territories but russia need to get away
its threat and russia regard the threat
from ukrainian territory is coming from
united states of america and nato which
from our point of view
are occupy ukraine politically and uh
it's a created
zone uh puppet regime it's one a threat
which russia will be insisted uh to take
out and we believe certainly that
artificially using chair or
this public regime make anti-russia from
ukraine make all you crunches ukraines
to hate russia and to prohibit by the
way russian language which is language
of the seventy percent of population and
thought and uh are also very important
to reclaim densification we absolutely
doesn't like when this aggressive regime
exists on our border so if this uh
russian concern will be taking an
account by uh the question
the question was about
something difficult about something to
russia's satisfaction being achieved by
may the ninth clearly you're saying uh
it can't happen uh given the scale of
that ambition dmitry babich do you see
something more limited being accepted by
russia fairly soon in terms of
autonomous regions perhaps in and around
the donbassland and the permanent
secession of crimea
well i think everything will depend on
the outcome of the battle you don't must
will russia be able to negotiate from
the position of strength
because the ukrainian delegation at the
talks which first took place in belarus
and they took place
in istanbul the ukrainian delegation
changed its stance several times
so obviously in order to achieve uh get
something from them we need to negotiate
from the position of strength that is
the position of president putin
and he will not meet zelianski until
there are some documents uh signed and
prepared and uh he will only meet
zelensky if they sit over the prepared
paper what the paper is going to be i
think no one knows even in russia
because just like with germany in 1945
we don't know
and the allies didn't know what kind of
regime would spin out there wouldn't be
a unified country or would it be a split
country
obviously russia will continue
recognizing the independence over these
two people's republics donaires can ask
will they join russia is an open
question i agree with
russia does not need that territory but
obviously if
the ukrainian army is defeated then
maybe russia may try
uh to negotiate more negotiate okay
some kind of statement
i'm sorry we're nearly we're coming
towards the end of the program but
dimitri babitz um you make a very valid
point there uh wolfgang richter that uh
ultimately the settlement of any
conflict uh depends
about
what happens on the battlefield wolfgang
richter so so the next few weeks and
months are going to be critical
absolutely you are right the next few
months are critical because the russian
forces are far stretched at the moment
if i look at all the ground forces
available including paratroopers and
marines and i found that almost
two-thirds of all russian troops are
engaged in ukraine and if you see the
long border lines of russia there are
other hot spots there are other travel
areas they cannot just take the reserves
out of these areas
be it the caucasus the central asian
part or the protection of fleet
uh
stations like mormons etc which are
important for nuclear issues and even in
the far east you see
certain developments that are not to the
desire of the russian leadership so the
russian forces are stretched for them
it's a decisive phase
the point is when it comes to the
question how the war could end
we still don't know the russian
objectives we have i have heard at least
three narratives the first one was
traditional security concerns
which we discussed for years
in the context of arms control
negotiations and it's about nato nato
expansion or the potential stationing
areas for troops and missiles this is
somewhat classical that one can't really
negotiate and that is reflected in the
draft treaties of the 17th of december
last year then we had another narrative
which is an imperial one that denies the
ukrainian identity the ukrainian
homogeneity etc and looks for historical
russian lands
taking
yeah so clearly that has to be
clearly those demands have to be scaled
down and the third one okay and the
third one we just heard taking out an
aggressive regime i asked who is
attacking whom exactly exactly
you don't know the objective yet and it
will be decided as you said okay
i'm sorry to jump into that wolfgang
richter but we we have a limited amount
of time louise jones i mean
for you what way could this end and
could it get to a settlement fairly soon
or are we looking at years here i think
we've got a way to run and you know they
keep coming up with these very nebulous
aims or let's talk about de-nazifying
you know the
famous quote about the roman empire they
made a desert and called it peace well
the russians are just making a desert of
southeast uh ukraine and the donbass and
saying it's de-nazified um
you know their complaints about the the
regime the government of president
zielinski um you know there's there's no
way that russia has got the capability
to affect the government of ukraine now
all that's going to happen is a very
long drawn-out battle we're going to
lose thousands more russian lives um you
know i don't know if either the
gentleman up there have got children if
they've been identified in the don mass
i'm very certain that president putin
has not sent any of his children to go
and die in the donbass and one thing's
for certain isn't it about any
settlement that it's ukraine's call you
know whatever the accusations have been
about president zielinski changing what
he will accept well that's up to them
they're the ones doing the fighting yeah
absolutely and president
uh zelensky has been very clear he
doesn't want to give up a single inch of
ukrainian soil so you know the russians
are just going to have to accept that
because they certainly don't have the
powers or the forces to be able to
change that over the long run you know
with the with the support that nato is
now stepping up unified nato
really russia is just going to have to
accept the inevitable coming their way
i'm afraid we're out of time thank you
very much indeed thanks to all my guests
to uh sergey markov and dmitry babich in
moscow wolfgang richter in berlin and of
course louise jones here with me in
westminster
and you are watching sky news tonight
coming up at eight o'clock the united
nations secretary general has called for
a ceasefire in ukraine as soon as
possible as he's visited president putin
in moscow and called for that ceasefire
to evacuate civilians from the besieged
port city of mariupol
[Music]
[Music]
you